[Musique]
les archives départementales de la
réunion inaugure une nouvelle exposition
retraçant la vie de l'aviateur
réunionnais roland-garros dans le cadre
des commémorations de la grande guerre
et à l'occasion du centenaire de sa
disparition
cette exposition retrace la vie et les
exploits de cet enfant du pays né à la
réunion en 1888 dans une famille créole
et à travers l'exposition c'est vraiment
la vie de garros qui est qui qui
défilent avec des pièces vraiment
d'origine qui se trouve aux archives
départementales et qui sont vraiment
superbement exposés et qui fait vibrer
cette exposition est vraiment ça donne
envie de visiter et de connaître cette
vie de roland garros pilotes téméraires
et inventif il a été le premier aviateur
à effectuer la traversée de la
méditerranée sans escale reliant ainsi
saint raphaël à bizerte sur son monoplan
il aura également combattu avec
l'aviation française au cours de la
seconde guerre mondiale toute son
histoire est retracée ici au travers de
cette exposition
là on présente des maquettes des avions
de roland garros qui sont des maquettes
en état de vol
une riche iconographie des des images
d'époque les journaux illustrés qui
relate les exploits de roland garros
qu'on essaye toujours de m en
contrepoint avec la presse locale qui
avec souvent un décalage de quelques
semaines va relater les mêmes les mêmes
exploits c'est une exposition qui est
vraiment à destination du grand public
facilement accessible qui plaira aussi
bien haut
aux enfants adolescents qu'aux parents
l'exposition roland-garros aviateurs
réunionnais visible aux archives
départementales de la réunion jusqu'au
28 juin 2019
[Musique]